The Joe Rogan Experience you were just
mentioning what China is doing to kind
of regulate its internet that's because
you're worth speaking about yeah have
you been following this yeah that's what
terrifies me is that we have to become
like China in order to deal with what
they're doing
um I I just I feel like one step moving
in that general direction is a social
credit score system and I'm terrified of
that and I think that that is where
vaccine passports lead to I really do
and I I think this idea that they're
slowly working their way into our
everyday lives and in this sort of
inexorable way where you have to have
some sort of paperwork or some sort of a
cue code or something on your phone or
QR code that scares the [ __ ] out of me
because that that's you're never gonna
get that back right once the government
has that kind of power and control
they're going to be able to exercise it
whenever they want with all sorts of
reasons to to Institute it I'm worried
about that too but I will say also just
to also notice that um everywhere
there's a way in which a small move in a
direction can be shown to lead to
another big Boogeyman and that boogeyman
makes us angry social media is up
regulating the meaning of everything to
be its worst possible conclusion so like
a small move by the government to do X
might be seen as this is the first step
in this total thing I'm not saying that
they're not going to go do that I'm
worried about that too but to also just
notice the way that social media
amplifies that do the degree to which we
all get kind of effective and triggered
by that the thing I think is worth
mentioning is what China is doing
regarding its internet because it's
seeing real problems and we might not
like their solution we might want to
implement a solution that has more civil
liberties than we should let's explain
what they're doing yeah so I'll do it
quickly so um
it's it's almost it's quite literally as
if Xi Jinping saw the social dilemma
because they've they've in the last two
months rolled out a bunch of sweeping
reforms that include things like
if you're under the age of 14 and you
use doyen which is their version of tick
tock when you swipe the videos instead
of getting like the influencer dancing
videos and soft pornography you get
science experiments you can do at home
Museum exhibits and patriotism videos
wow so you're scrolling and you're
getting stuff that's educating because
they want their kids to grow up and want
to be astronauts and scientists yeah
they don't want them to grow up and be
influencers uh and I'm not when I say
this by the way I'm not just be clear
I'm not praising that model just
noticing all the things that you're
doing well I'll praise it another you
can influence people that's a great way
to do it they also limit it to
um three hours sorry 40 minutes a day on
Tick Tock for gaming let me actually do
the tick tock example so they do 40
minutes a day for tick tock they also
when you scroll a few times they
actually do a mandatory five second
delay saying hey do you want to get up
and do something else like because when
people sit there infinitely scroll even
Tim Cook recently said mindless
scrolling which is actually invented by
my co-founder of the center for Humane
technology Asia Raskin he invented he
was in the social dilemma he's the one
who invented that infinite scroll thing
China said hey we don't want people
mindlessly scrolling so after you scroll
a few videos it does a mandatory five
second like interlude they also have
opening hours and closing hours so from
10 pm until six in the morning if you're
under 14 it's like it's closed meaning
one of the problems of social media for
teenagers is if I'm not on at one in the
morning but all my friends are on and
they're still commenting on my stuff I
feel the social pressure I'm going to be
ostracized if I don't participate and if
your notifications are on your phone
keeps buzzing totally and even if
they're not on it's like oh but I want
to see if they said something about my
thing and so um it's it's a it's a we
call a multi-polar trap if I don't
participate but the other guys are I'm
going to lose out and Facebook and these
companies they know that by the way even
Netflix said their biggest competitor is
sleep so one of the um because they're
all competing for attention
so when you do this mandatory thing
where you say we're going to close from
10 P.M to 6 in the morning suddenly
everyone if you're in the same time zone
it's another important side effect uh
can't use it at the same time so these
are some examples for their military by
the way when you if you're a member of
the Chinese uh pla Army
um you you get a lockdown smartphone
it's like a light phone it's like hyper
locked down you can't do anything by
contrast we know that Russia and China
go into our veterans groups on Facebook
and they actually try to sow
disinformation try to radicalize
Veterans hey Afghanistan happened aren't
you really pissed let me show you 10
videos right and this is like dosing
people with more mental health problems
right so in in a bunch of different ways
we specifically if you want to drive
Civil War in a meaningful way in the U.S
take the people who have real tactical
capability and radicalize them
and so Target those groups in particular
and that's like that's it makes sense
why their military wants to lock down
the ability for external influence of
course right and so while we're you know
spending all this money building
physical borders building walls or you
know spending 50 billion dollars a year
on the passport controls in the
Department of Homeland Security and the
physical you know Russia trying to try
to fly a plane into the United States
we've got Patriot missiles to shoot it
down but when they try to fly an
information like Precision guided
information bomb we instead of
responding with Patriot missiles we
respond with here's a white glove
Facebook algorithm that says which ZIP
code or Facebook group would you like to
Target right so it changes the
asymmetries typically what made us power
what made the US powerful was the
geographic
um you know we had these huge oceans on
both sides it gives us unique you know
place in the world when you move to the
digital world it erases that Geographic
asymmetry of power so this is a imminent
national security threat this is not
just like hey social media is adding
some subtle pollution in the form of
mental health or Aid it's adding a
little bit of polarization but we can
still get things done on it's an
imminent national security threat to our
continuity of our model of governance
which we want to keep spoken to people
in power have you spoken to Congress
people
about this yes but I'm hoping many more
of them watch this because I think
people need to see the full scope and I
really do want to make sure we're not
sounding like just full disaster porn
because we want to get don't worry about
that go full disaster porn well it's
just better than that than not we it's
not meant to scare people just to get an
appraisal of what is the situation it's
going to scare the reality is going to
reality is scary it's it should scare
people because we we're so far behind
the eight ball there's a really
important Point Tristan was just at that
we actually need to double click on
which is that democracies are more
affected by what's happening with social
media than authoritarian of course
nations are and for a number of reasons
but do you wanna well and we sort of
hinted at it earlier but when social
media's business model is showing each
tribe their Boogeyman their extreme
reality it forces a more polarized
political base which means to get
elected you have to say something that's
going to appeal to a base that's more
divided and in the Facebook files that
Francis Howe can put out they showed
that when Facebook changed the way its
ranking system worked in 2018 to
something called meaningful social
interactions I won't go in the details
they talked to political parties in
Europe so here we are it's 2018 they do
an interview with political parties in
Poland and Hungary and Taiwan and India
and these political parties say Facebook
we know you changed your ranking system
and Facebook like smugly responds yeah
everyone has a conspiracy theory about
how we change our ranking system because
those stories go viral and they're like
no no we know that you changed how your
ranking system works because we used to
be able to publish here's a white paper
on our agriculture policy to deal with
like soil degradation and now when we
publish the white paper we get crickets
we don't get any response and we tested
it and the only thing that we get at
traffic and attention on is when we say
negative things about the other
political parties so and they say we
know that's bad we don't want to do that
we don't want to like run our campaign
that's about saying negative things
about the other party but when you
change the algorithm that's the only
thing we can do to get attention it
shows how Central the algorithm is to
everything else if I'm Tucker Carlson or
Rachel Maddow or anybody who's a
political personality are they really um
saying things just for their TV audience
are they also appealing to the algorithm
because most more and more of their
attention is going to happen Downstream
in these little clips that get filtered
around so they they also need to appeal
to how the algorithm is rewarding saying
negative things about the other party so
what that does is it means you elect a
more political like representative class
that's based on disagreeing with the
other side and being divided about the
other side which means that it throws a
gear into the rent a wrench into the
gears of democracy and means that
democracy stops delivering results in a
time where we have more crisis we have
more supply chain stuff and inflation
and all these other things to respond to
and instead of responding effectively
it's just division all the way down